if you're a high value dude like it
inverted comment whatever that means
right are you really going to have time
to be doing all these like crazy
activities you know what I'm saying it's
going to be anybody who puts a lot of
money on the first day is just asking to
get taken advantage well I actually
don't like it because I don't I don't
want anyone to like expect any like I
feel like like I don't want anyone to
expect anything so do you feel the
pressure of that like do you feel like
if a guy does like like normally if he
does like too much early on where I'm
just like I'm trying to get to know you
and see like I don't want to feel like
champagne five kids and all this little
much well I was like you you could have
started with a second date before the
proposal I don't know but